so yeah I'm gonna be giving a survey on
on mcsp so what's the survey gonna be
like so I'm gonna be focusing mostly on
the on a few important papers in the
area and mentioning the main questions
so it's going to be sort of a conceptual
map of the area especially for those of
you who haven't seen the problem before
and don't really understand why yeah
people are working on it I hope you give
some motivation so that's what Alex said
yesterday when he presented as a result
he said the motivation will be tomorrow
and you'll get more motivation than you
need probably so yeah so let's get
started so what is mcsp so here's the
the most basic version of the problem
right so um I record you to find this
yesterday but I just want to make sure
we're all on the same page so the input
was just a truth table of a boolean
function on n bits on little n bits so
I'm the bull the truth tables of size 2
to the little ends let's call a capital
N and you're given a parameter s right
and the question is does this boolean
function represented by this truth table
have a circuit of size at most s right
so this is just a basic version of the
question and there are lots of variants
you could ask several of which are
interesting in their own right and then
there are interesting relationships
between them so one natural kind of
variant of this is well why do we care
only about boolean circuits how about
circuits of other kinds right so we can
ask more generally if you have circuits
from a Class C does F have C circuits of
size at most s and call at CMC SP and
and in fact in general you can talk
about other complexity measures so it
doesn't just have to be circuit size or
for some class of circuits it could be
some of the measures we've seen already
earlier in the workshop so it could be a
proximate degree to the communication
complexity your favorite complexity
measure for all of these measures the
envelope of this problem
as interesting right okay so this is a
decision version of mcsp so you're
asking whether F has small circuits
there also several other questions you
could ask so you could for example ask
given the function what the smallest
circuit size is right that's
optimization version and if you can
solve the decision version you can use
binary search to solve the optimization
version so that you can also ask the
search version right so there's a very
kind of natural kind of object which
witnesses that f has a circular size
that was just namely the circuit itself
so given F you could ask to find the
circuit of size at most s so that's the
search version and in some cases we'll
be interested in approximate version of
this where we don't want where we relax
the requirement that we ask for this
precise circuit computing the function
and I'm happy with that
computing the function on most inputs
right so that's the search version they
could also ask for example the average
case complexity version so we might not
yeah we might not need to solve this
problem on all inputs we might be happy
solving it on most inputs in some sense
and this will come up later and they
talk and it'll be kind of important part
of the connections to other other areas
of complexity theory and they could also
not give F explicitly so this giving you
a lot of information right to give you
the entire truth table of F and ask you
for that as small circuits you could
just give some set of inputs of F or
together with the values of F on those
inputs and ask whether that's consistent
with a small circuit right so this
problem is very closely related to
learning to learning theory because you
want to know whether there's a small
hypothesis consistent with your set of
samples and that will be an interesting
question as well though we won't be
talking about it very much in this in in
this survey so these are just found the
variance of mcsp yeah we will be looking
at so so this is a lower bound semester
and but my argument isit if interested
low bounds you should be interested in
mcsp because every low bound is a no
instance of mcsp
right so every lower bound and somehow
for some complexity measure saying that
there's a function which doesn't have a
small complexity measure okay but
that still doesn't really tell us why
she interests in the complexity of mcsp
I mean why do we need to study mcsp is a
computational problem and and how that
help us so just in general kind of
problems like mcsp tend to be very
informative so knowing what the
complexity tends to give us a lot of
information because of somehow this meta
computational nature that the problem
has right so you're given kind of an
instance and you want to know about some
kind of like the instance itself encodes
an algorithm or a question about an
algorithm and you want to know about
that so somehow the question is does
there exist an algorithm to decide if
some kind of algorithmic question is
true and questions of this sort tend to
be very important in computer science in
general and complexity or in particular
it so for example there's a sad question
right so sack question is also this kind
of a competition question by given a
circuit and you want to know whether it
has a satisfying assignment and these
problems actually sat in mcsp can be
thought of as sort of duals of each
other because inside you've given a
circuit and you want information about
it so you want to know the circuit is
satisfiable and the counting version you
want to know what the number of
satisfying assignments is for qbf
satisfiability you perhaps want to
evaluate some formula on the truth table
computed by the circuit in general there
are various kinds of information you
want about the truth table computer by a
circuit and those give you variants of
sad in mcsp is just the sum how the
inverse question right you're given the
truth table and you want to know whether
there are small circuits so sad somehow
corresponds to kind of white box
questions where you're given a
competition along jected you want to
know about the function computed by it
and mcsp corresponds to black box
computation you're given the function as
carbon Oracle in some sense and you want
to know about small representations of
it and about complexity questions about
the function and our understanding of
satis off paired off in many ways right
throughout complexity theory so when the
earliest results was cook-levin theorem
and the NP completeness of sat led to
understanding the the complexities of
many other problems in relation to Sat
then there's the kokrak hawk programming
proof complexity which is also kind of
focused around Sat there's the PCP
theorem and all its implications for the
hardest approximation
Morrisey
simply there's sort of Ryan's approach
to using algorithms for SAP to prove low
bounds so in all of these cases somehow
having more information of the
complexity of circuits that helps us
gain somehow a better understanding of
complexity theory and I'd like to argue
that somehow mcsp should be equally
useful in terms of things that we figure
out about it so it's a problem with much
less well study than sat for various
reasons that explain some of them but if
we do figure out more things about it I
think the the benefits would be would be
quite significant so there's just maybe
a couple of other sort of perspectives
of ways to look at mcsp that I'd like to
mention one is this kind of perspective
in terms of the of individual strings
and their complex chain where they
random or not right so in some sense
you're asking whether so this truth
table is essentially a string of length
two to little n and you're asking if
less small complexity and what are the
complexity measure you choose by any
reasonable measure you choose a random
string is not gonna have small
complexity right so random string is
going to be a no instance and comes like
somehow some structured instances are
going to be yes instances so in some
sense is asking whether our input is
random or not and this is kind of a
perspective that yeah kind of connects
the problem to questions think of
computability theory where there's combo
of random strings and you want to know
whether a string is Co number of random
or not and took on various other
questions in between complexity in
computer buddy theory and Erik actually
has several excellent surveys adopting
this perspective and looking at what
this tells us about the complexity of
mcsp but I won't be saying much more
about that here and even if you don't
care about some how these kind of meta
computational questions may be mcsp is
interesting just because it's just a
question with compressing strings I mean
a circuit is just a compressed version
of a string and you're extracting the
string from it and kind of an implicit
way by evaluating the circuit at each
input and the question is are there
short descriptions of the song of this
form and because circuits are simple
common to all objects somehow this is a
simple contour problem which we try to
understand so
that's yeah that's maybe what some other
perspective mcsp which might not be that
useful perhaps okay so that's a kind of
a few kind of questions the perspectives
and mcsp so I so that's so far it's been
sort of philosophical so I'd like to
kind of make things more concrete now
and try to tell you about the
connections mcsp has to other parts of
complexity theory but what the main
questions are and so cope so something
that's quite easy to see for any natural
version of mcsp is that mcsp is an NP
right because you've given the truths
paper and you want know the small
circuits you can just guess a circuit of
size at most s and you can just evaluate
it on each input and yeah and check that
it computes is truth table correctly and
because the truth table is a larger
object of size due to the little end
this is only going to cost you time like
s times two to the n to verify once
you've guessed the circuit so so mcsp is
an NP problem exactly yeah yeah right
right exactly yeah so or two to the S
yeah or two dog hotel divest on so yeah
so it's really an FPT in some sense so
if you think of this as a parameterized
problem and s is the parameter it's an
FPT because it only depends expression
in a parameter or not in your input okay
yeah so related to that even though most
of the talk will be thinking about mcsp
other parameter included in some cases
it will be useful convenient or in some
records even important to think of the
un-- parametric version where we have
fixed size function and we want to know
about mcsp of s where this s was fixed
as a function of n so for example you
could think of
MCS P of n to the point 1 capital n to
the point 1 which is really asking
whether the truth table has circus of
size 2 to the point 1 times little n or
not so so I mean clearly yeah in this
question reduces to this one but yeah
but it's sometimes very interesting to
to consider this ok so so we've seen
that mcsp is an NP and as I said it's
even an FPT but but it's it np-hard
right and this is somehow the central
question about mcsp so I'll be spending
the first part of my talk we are talking
about
about the possible NP hardness of mcs
tree and it seems that there's no kind
of way of solving MCS people are looking
at all possible circuits right we don't
really get much information from
checking with a some circuit yeah
consoles if it doesn't solve mcsp we
don't really get information for other
circuits so it's sort of unclear how to
solve mcsp by an exponential time but
yeah I mean that's just a way knife
thing that we are trying maybe there are
more clever ways of doing it so yes so
this question the NP hardness is kind of
a question it presents itself almost
immediately and then the other question
is well if we find it we don't manage
blues NP hard can we at least get
evidence that is not in P is there
something I can say about whether or not
M CSP is in polynomial time so that's
something else if we look at and we look
at other structural features so other
features of NP problems problems in NP
and we see that mcsp behaves somewhat
are unusually the respect to these
features so and the way we will kind of
present this is to look at it in
comparison to sat right so sat has very
lots of different features which we
understand quite well and we'll kind of
like do a comparison on case-by-case
basis of what's true for Sat and whether
the same kind of thing is true fancy SP
or not and if not what does it say about
mcsp right so so throughout the talk
have in mind kind of sat as a case to
compare with with regard to things I'm
talking about okay okay so the so the
first thing I'm going to talk about is
actually a lot of interest especially
explicit constructions quite briefly
because they don't comment on the
question of NP hardness right so so so
what's an expense reconstruction so let
me just define it so explicit
construction is just an algorithm that
allows you to get your hands on in on
inputs yes and no inputs of different
lengths right
explicit construction for a property cue
which is just a set then zero one set of
strings in zero one is a fully time
computable yeah let's say that this F
takes kind of you re inputs and goes to
zero one star such that we want for all
n F of one to the end to be in Q
intersect zero one to the end so let's
just ignore the cases where Q is empty
on some input lengths as it has been CSP
when yeah the input lines are not a
power of two then I mean clearly there's
no s instances let's just restrict
ourselves to instances for which Q is
non empty stop start sorry yeah so this
one explicit construction that's for
every so you give the input length and
you Larry and when you give that there's
an efficient procedure which computes
for you some string that's in Q right
and it's fairly easy to see that natural
and P complete problems L is a standard
np-complete problem it's a natural
np-complete problems Ln L complement
have explicit constructions
right so if you think of sad vertex
cover click and so on it's pretty
trivial to give a construction of a yes
instance or no instance of each input
length right that's completely trivial
so part of what's complicated about mcsp
is that even this this very kind of
standard feature of many natural
problems in NP is kind of related to one
of our main open questions like so it's
just a proposition so explicit
construction
so the complement of mcsp where you have
we maybe take the unpasteurized versions
so let's say n 2.1 there's not too hard
to see yeah i mean i yeah so it it's
it's it's a fairly short proof so if you
have an explicit construction of
something that's a hard truth table that
doesn't have circuits of size n to the
point one that's going to give you a
very hard function in e so that's kind
of a fundamental kind of problem in
circuit complexity which we have quite
far from solving and the converse is
true as well right so even getting
explicit constructions for kind of this
this problem are very hard and somehow
this difficulty underlies some of what
prevents us from gaining a better
understanding of mcsp in general as I'll
explain later but this is just quite a
simple example of that so I should just
mention in passing that so yeah for
natural np-complete problems the
language and it's complement have
explicit constructions by the natural
problems in P for which we don't yet
know this right so if you take for
example primes which is the problem in P
we don't have explicit constructions in
polynomial time for that take Ramsey
graphs the document parameters we don't
have Ponte constructions for that so
some of the complexity of deciding q is
it always kind of correlated with how
easy easy it is to have an explicit
construction yeah so there's some
properties for which yeah which are easy
to decide but the only no expresses
constructions under D transition
assumptions and and others which are
very hard to decide which explicit
instructions are easy right and I think
Valentin might say is something more
about explicit constructions and the
talk later
in the morning ok so any questions about
this so this is just a very kind of a
simple starting point at comparing side
and mcsp sat and stack complement of
easy express constructions but mcsp does
not right yes yes yeah so I should have
mentioned so yeah when I was mentioning
all the different variants are actually
mentioned also the approximation version
right so but you want to know so in so
given a parameter instead of being given
just a parameter s your given parameter
C and s and you want to know say yes of
the circuit size that most s know of
exactly C and in fact this sort of
approximation version and the
relationship between C and s will be
important in the last part of the talk
so yeah so that's an important question
too yeah okay yeah we should probably be
more aware of even though we all know
which is that there's a big difference
between combination of difficulty and
computational expressed ability and we
tend to complete for the notion of
completeness says that many cases we
these coincide but that's not true all
the time so problems that are that are
more expressive we think of as having
higher complexity but that is not it's
only a weak indication that they're more
difficult than other problems right
right for example right so for example
the ability to easily find up yes and no
instances might indicate it's harder to
show average case hardness it might only
average case hardness for example I mean
so that might be one kind of thing
that's related to but yes yeah so um
yeah it's a good point in especially
relevant to mcsp okay
so that's for explicit obstructions go
so now let's get to the main kind of
question about mcsp the main open
questions one which most of research and
the problem has focused expression of NP
hardness yeah so it's just is mcsp and
be hard or not and so mcsp is sort of a
very kind of interesting case here in
that it's a natural example for problems
which we have no strong evidence either
of NP hardness or the prom isn't np-hard
right so we know that if we take a
problem of a choice problem that we
happen to encounter naturally then it's
quite often easy and polynomial time
it's easy in some sense or it's np-hard
right so that's a phenomenon that we see
in general there are some problems that
don't seem to fit into this so for
example factoring
graph isomorphism but for these problems
we have evidence that they're not
np-hard I mean the np-hard the poll on
hierarchy collapses there's some
complexity attic evidence that these
problems aren't np-hard
so mcsp is sort of an unusual example of
a problem for which so far we don't
really have much evidence either in
favor of NP hardness or against it
so in some sense it's wide open and if
you ask people working on the problem
then they're all probably have different
beliefs about whether is np-hard or not
I certainly believe it is but there
might be others who don't so so so what
is it about mcsp that makes this come NP
hardness question tricky or hard to
understand so kind of a kind of a
important insight into this was from
this sort of paper by by Valentin and
Ginni sigh on the circuit minimization
problem so this is an in mm and this is
really the paper that got research and
mcsp and going again so M CSP has a very
kind of rich history in some sense
because there's a lot of work on it and
the Soviet Union the fifties and sixties
you could read about some of this
interrupts and brought survey so it was
a very natural problem from the
perspective circuit memorization and it
was looked at but um I think well it
just wasn't much work but hearten or
what a save of the problem in a formal
sense so in fact I mean Eric reports
that Levin delayed his publication of
his NP caprice reserve because he hoped
to show something about the N peak of
Peters mcsp he didn't he couldn't do
that and you still don't know how to do
it he did say something or DN apps but
mcsp in general we it's still wide open
but this paper of Verity it's ingenious
somehow brought the problem our kind of
into focus again and had some very
interesting insights into it especially
into this question of NP hardness so
kind of an important result in the paper
so this is from cabañal side
is that we can't it's going to be hard
to to give the sorts of np-hardness
reductions that we used to right so when
you want to prove that a problem is
np-hard we find gadgets we kind of
construct a reduction that works and the
sort of thing that works for other NP
problems isn't going to work in a
straightforward way for mcsp right so so
what they show is that if there are nice
and reductions and the core the result
is really that um there's a sort of
explicit construction obstacle for mcsp
right we don't know how to explicitly
construct no instances IMC SP and this
sort of kind of lack of knowledge on our
part translates to a lack of knowledge
and how to construct reductions and let
me just sort of explain how that goes
kind of like let's just take the version
of mcsp where we have the parameter set
to say n to the point one so so we have
that and we have mcsp complement m6 p
with some set parameter and okay so we
need to somehow control the kinds of
reductions that we use to be the sort
that were typically used and our notion
of nice for this for this kind of toy
result somehow will be that the eruption
doesn't shrink the input that much so
that said that's all we need so it's a
polynomial time reduction and it doesn't
shrink the input too much because it's a
reduction it Maps a complement to mcsp
compliment and sattva mcsp but as I said
before for natural np-complete problems
there are easy explicit construction so
there's an easy explicit construction of
font size for in formulas thus trivial
ones just compose a construction with
the reduction and you
get a heart function right so it's a
very simple idea but I think it has very
interesting implications because it's
the sort of result that that really
raises this question so what does it
really say about np-hardness right so it
says that there aren't nice well it
doesn't really say that np-hardness is
likely or unlikely it's just saying that
it's hard to show right and it sort of
raises the question what is it about
these reductions as a problem is it that
they're M reductions is it that they're
nice if we can strengthen the notion of
reduction can we still show results of
this form if we we connect and we just
rule out reductions unconditionally it
sort of raises the whole host of
questions about the kinds of reductions
we can hope to use and what the notion
of reduction has to do with with
hardness and showing hardness right so
this actually led to sort of like a long
line of work so by just give you a few
examples for example there's Ryan and
Cody Williams then there's Hitchcock and
Pavan there's Shree Qi and Osama
Watanabe this Eric D Raj and Valentin
yeah so I think there's erican and Suchi
and so on and so forth so there's been
like a long line of works where you kind
of play with the notion of reduction you
have here you see what kinds of
consequences we get so the trying to
show that even for gang weak notions of
reductions somehow you get some sort of
complex genetic implication from a
hardest result which we don't know how
to show right and I'll just maybe
mention one result out of these because
it kind of rules our production to a
certain form and that's this blood of
Cody and Ryan's
so they say there are no end to the
point one local reductions so what's the
local reduction a local reduction is
just one that looks at a few of the
input bits right and in fact the known
np-hardness is upset we know almost all
of them work under these local
reductions under these d long time
uniform projections where you only look
at a few bits of the input and then you
decide what the output bit of the
reduction is and what what cody and ryan
show is that even if you will allow this
amount of locality you would even be
able to reduce parity to mcsp and it
sort of uses a similar idea to the kind
of cabinet's I idea but it's just a what
they do is to show that if there is such
a reduction then you can have small ac0
circuits for parity and that's a
contradiction somehow you can take
advantage of locality to kind of get
small circuits and other under
interesting aspect of this result is
that there's no sort of niceness
constraint right so they are made this
niceness constrained so this just works
for any reduction as long as it's local
so yeah so this is kind of like a clear
result it shows that there's certain
reductions that just don't work but yeah
I mean we have a lot of freedom in terms
of which notional reduction we use and
it seems to be the root of the
difficulty is really this explicit
construction obstacle right these
results all seem to take advantage of
that so what if we somehow given kind of
a hard truth stable for free does this
help us at all so I think that's a very
natural question so
the question is mcsp and be hard so
there's some work on this when the
reductions are very simple for example
constant depth circuits but when they
can be polynomial size circuits there's
essentially nothing known as the best of
my knowledge so and and this is I think
a question that's mostly quite
interesting to think about regard the NP
hardness the result is for non your form
draft medicine and the local reductions
right which are very simple so here if
you love polynomial size I mean it the
file uniformity is pretty crucial and
very very well I guess they need to well
they need to construct these so it's
these circuits
right from the reduction its uniform P
crucial about right you remember
but uniform tears it's not just locality
but yeah I kind of like because it's
written you know they did think give it
a nun the show that there's no reduction
from parity and non-uniformly
there is a reduction - well not mcsp but
em KTP tell them show me the difference
between those yeah yeah so perhaps
uniformity is crucial there by me and so
it's it's not complete clear to me but
yeah certainly for non-uniform
reductions we don't really know no no so
there's also some the negative results
the ones I mentioned involve are kind of
like other notions reductions troops
table reductions some recent work with
Mike Sachs but during reductions so
there's yeah so there's like a range of
reductions are considered so that's on
the possibility of course I mean if you
kind of like I love the use of cue in
reductions but they're I don't really
expect it to help you very much I think
non-uniformity randomness is more what's
likely to help okay so okay so that's
the status of the mcsp problem for
general circuits but we could kind of
like look at it a different wave so we
could consider so we've defined CMC SPME
could look at some simple a class or
circuits right so it seems that the
reason why we aren't able to show NP
hardness results is because we don't
know how to show super normal circuit
lower bounds but there are lots of
models for which we do know how to show
Super Bowl on circuit low bands I mean
for DNS for AC or circuits it's robot P
and so on so if you consider these
models do you get maybe kind of a
hardness result if you look at the term
low bound techniques in the proper way
so what's the complexity of mcsp we copy
for we can see
and there's so it's a bit unintuitive
actually because you would think that if
you should asking about a weaker circuit
Class C the prom should really be easier
I mean the circuit class is more complex
kind of knowing whether there's a small
circuit from the class or not should be
a harder problem but we don't know
anyway to make this formal so it's not
clear how to make that formal I mean of
course is true for satisfiability if you
have a larger class of circuits then the
problem gets harder but here if the
class of circuits gets larger it's not
clear that kind of like a simpler class
of circuits mcsp reduces to and CSP for
larger class of circuits and that's
because we're if you have a function of
low kind of complexity for some simple
class circus of course it's still simple
for the harder class but the other way
around it's not so clear how to get a
reduction how to transform hard
functions for an easy class for a simple
class of circuits two hard functions
from a more complicated class right so
somehow it's kind of non monotone notion
at least as far as we understand that C
mcsp is complexity it's not quite
monotone and C so and in fact for DNF
mcsp we we do know quite a bit so this
been known for quite a while or since
the 70s so DN f mcsp
and somehow this isn't so surprising
because what is the the complexity of
deciding where the truth table has small
DNFs or not what you want to do is
really cover the truth table kind of the
ones the truth table by a sort of sub
cubes which are all one right because
each term of the DNF corresponds to a
sub cube in the in the hamming cube
right a sub cube which is all once we're
setting some of the variables to zeros
and ones and the restaurant left free
and you have an or at the top in the
enchiridion F which is just the union of
these kind of sub cubes so this question
is really whether you can cover the ones
of the string by a set of one sub cubes
and that's sort of essentially a set
cover problem and it's kind of a
structured version a set cover problem
and you can reduce that cover to do this
problem and then that's what Masek did
so is ocean reduction is quite
complicated but it's simplified in later
work like Eric Antonia and warden and
some of this work and it's it's not be
np-complete and not just that it's known
that you can approximate the problem to
a factor n right and that just follows
from the fact it's a specific set cover
instance so there's a specific set cover
instance underlying it and just by
solving the set cover instance
approximately which we know how to do
you can approximate the problem so just
to re-emphasize what approximation means
it's a question that you our last about
is there's a gap right so see if there's
a circuit of you want to distinguish
between having sets of size s and not
having such the size s times some K and
here K is is little n so we just use
capital n log N
okay so so that's something so at least
there are Russians of natural plaster c4
which is np-complete but I mean we know
about techniques for many more classes
right not just vnf so what can we say
about more general classes so not very
much it seems at least so far but might
very well be that people just haven't
looked at this very much I don't know
it's certainly worth looking at in more
detail so that's sort of a recent result
of mine with the Igor and Shuichi so the
in F sub X sauce she's just a slightly
slightly more complex to measure that
mcsp is np-hard but yeah this is just a
little bit of progress and I mean this
there's still a lot left to do so for
one question is what about AC zero
circuits right so let's kind of give
some flexibility with the notion of
reduction so let's say quasi polynomial
time reductions because we don't yet
know how to show explicit functions that
have purely exponential size is zero
circuit lower bounds only
sub-exponential so let's allow the
reduction to be bit weaker so
quasi-polynomial time reductions and
yeah so I think this is a good question
and in general I think in terms of
trying to understand the circuit class
see I mean yeah after all this
complexity is you trying to understand
complexity measures so they're sort of
proving NP hardness results for CMC SP
where CS is as general a class as
possible as interesting direction
because in some sense you're saying
something about the about all functions
and the C complexities so the lower
bound result is just saying that here's
one function or sequence of functions
that doesn't have small circuits here
you're talking about all functions in
some sense so it gives you more
information so I think we're very
interesting for the non low bow
to try to use the techniques they're an
awkward show whether you can do it in a
black box way but maybe using the
techniques used to prove these lower
bounds to extend them to show hardness
results for SEM CSP for larger classes
see so ya fix a depth then you want to
show that it's enough to take a fixed
essence function event so well I mean
you could scale it down so you probably
show on the ETH that it would be hard
but for that case yeah yeah yes no so
yeah we can term approximate and
quasi-polynomial times within the same
approximation factor and you also have
hardness approximation result which is
doesn't match the positive result it's
like log log n probably log log n so
there's some gap there it's - yeah I
should I should mention that here
there's also been quite a bit of work on
in approximately results not just
showing that DNF mcsp is np-complete but
it's hard to approximate the circuit
size to within so on log n factor and
there's a line of work
kind of yeah stemming from work and pcps
and learning theory which gets a handle
on this I think it's known that it's
hard within the approximate in fact log
and 1 minus Epsilon
as far as I know yeah under some
assumption it's standard assumption okay
so yeah so that's about the sort of the
hardness of mcsp the NP hardness or
hardness under standard for standard
notions of hormuz so now let's look at
the question of whether mcsp s and P and
what evidence we can give against it
right so so far we have a sample
hardness result but for mcsp in general
for boolean circuits we have no evidence
at all that it's not in for normal time
I mean from what I said this talk so
let's look at that question
so yes is so or maybe that is so so the
question of whether mcsp
is in polynomial time or not somehow the
work on it has also given us information
about the average case hardness mcsp and
I'll tell you what it means for MC speed
average average case hard pseudo
randomness and those connections will
see randomness and the famous of natural
proofs paper of Ross program proved that
yeah so I guess one of the contributions
of the of the cabinet side paper I
mentioned earlier is pointing out what
the natural proofs obstacle has to say
with complex um CSP and in fact for me
at least that's been the most productive
way to view that paper I mean we think
of it usually as kind of a barrier as
well saying certain proof techniques
don't work but I think in terms of
getting information or mcsp and its
status the competition problem that's
for me the the real kind of contribution
of that paper so so yeah the question
we're asking is is mcsp in polynomial
time or not and we want to give evidence
against it so that the key notion that
gives us some some insight into this
question is the notion of natural proofs
to turn off wrong foolish so so what is
the natural proof so unnatural proof
useful against let's say we have a class
of circuit C and we have a size
parameter s and after proof useful
against see us it's just a dense such
polynomial time subset of the heart
functions right so let's say these are
these are all truth tables so let's say
these are all these are all the hard
ones and natural proof is just yeah
these are the hard and yeah a natural
proof Q is just a polynomial time
decidable subset of the of the heart
functions that's dense that has
significant kind of fraction of his
weight on the non the or the uniform
distribution over inputs right so that's
so that's just an interpretation of of
natural proofs in terms of events ESP
and well I mean what kind of observation
is that this is corresponds to a very
natural notion of average case easiness
friends ESP under the uniform
distribution right so so if you just
take uniform distribution for zero error
algorithms under the uniform
distribution this is essentially what it
means for a natural proof to exist right
so the Q is in polynomial time yeah so
here's the sort of observation that I
had with Luigi and a paper from last
year natural proof
equivalent to um mcsp of s average so
what does it mean to be easy on average
for zero algorithms you just take the
uniform distribution so there's no other
uniform distribution over un so you just
take the uniform distribution and you
want to either give the correct answer
or you want to say you don't know right
so that's that's a zero or a logarithm
and what means to be easy on average is
that you just do this with significant
probability over the the uniform
distribution so it's a inverse
polynomial probability it's pretty easy
to see that if there are national proofs
then you get such an algorithm right
because if you just check membership in
queue and if it says yes then you say
yes otherwise you just say don't know
and this falls the mcsp with significant
fraction or the of the uniform
distribution and the other way around
just follows from the fact that M CSP is
so kind of biased somehow because most
functions are hard functions so if you
have a zero order algorithm you just
sort of throw away the inputs on which
you get a zero right and you're still
left with signature in fraction of
inputs and so you get natural proof from
that right but but I think looking at
things in this way in terms of the
average KC's another mcsp is this is
somewhat useful so so what a roster on
Druid shows a roster on rulers showed
that under standard to the graphic
assumption
especially hard one-way functions exist
under a standard kind of cryptographic
assumption about one-way functions that
are very hard there are no natural
proofs that are useful against
polynomial size circuits and not emoji
it just means that mcsp is hard on
average right so on this cryptographic
assumptions implies that that mcsp is
hard an average I mean of course natural
proofs have kind of several other
implications the motivations from proof
complexity and and so on but the purpose
of this talk kind of just yeah kind of
restrict attention to to what it implies
by mcsp
and well what's how does the proof go so
once you have the basic ingredients is
finally kind of straightforward and
here's just proof my picture so it's
well known that based on especially hard
one-way functions that you can
constructs you random function
generators which are family of c random
functions where each function is small
circuit complexity but no kind of
efficient test can distinguish such
functions from random ones right so
let's just take such a family of so
random functions so they're all in this
easy set right because each of these
pseudo-random functions a small circuit
complexity but if you have a natural
proof then because the natural proof is
in polynomial time that's an efficient
test which distinguishes random
functions from C random ones right C
random ones none of them is in queue and
random ones the significant fraction of
them is in queue so under this
assumption you have that there are no
natural pools so it's kind of very
straightforward once you have the
required machinery I mean to go from one
wave functions to surround function
generators you need this result of go
right Goldust and Macaulay but yeah I
mean beyond that it's fairly
straightforward
and in fact you can get more Jam
the pseudo-random functions computable
by circuits from a Class C then CMC SP
is hard on average right I mean it's
just the proof just goes through on the
same way okay so that tells that tells
us something about the like neural mcsp
being it beyond the cryptographic
assumptions we don't expect that to
happen so yes that's a good point but
there's a trade-off so if you only
assume like super normally hard one wave
functions then you get this known after
proofs against kind of mcsp with the
parameter that's polynomial n to the
epsilon right so under that assumption
you'll get that mcsp with n to the
epsilon parameter as hard on average so
it's just as a simple trade-off between
in terms of how it can start arriving
functions there's trade off and so I'm
just stating kind of the version of it
which rules out even there's kind of
like much simpler version of CMC SP but
it's true yeah that's kind of a a
parametric kind of trade off and I mean
one of the nice things about kind of
thinking about CMC SP on average is that
there's a feature I mentioned before or
mcsp that we don't know how to relate
kind of CMC SP to C Prime and C SP when
C and C prime are different we don't
know how they reduce to each other but
clearly if you look in an average case
notion if C is a simpler class then if C
Prime and C SP is easy an average so a
CMC SP and that's fairly easy to see
right because I mean a random function
is going to be hard even for the harder
class and an easy function is going to
be solved by algorithm for the for the
harder class and therefore also for the
easier class so when you look at average
case complexity you get this kind of
monotone stree in terms of the
complexity of CMC SP which is good and
you also get sort of natural kind of
relationship between CMC SP for a
parameter s and for a parameter s prime
s and s prime are different Eric
mentioned this in yesterday that we
don't really know in general how these
relate to each other but the average
case notion it's trivial to see that if
you can solve CMC s P of s prime for s
prime bigger than s then you can also
sell CMC s P of s on average right
without any observation you can also use
it in the other direction right so we
have natural poops against AC zero in
absence cup then you would get it it's
easy on average yes yeah so yeah for DNS
for example right for DNS is np-hard in
the worst case but natural proofs tell
you there's easy on average so there we
have kind of a gap right so there's an
epi hottest result for the precise
complexity but on average is easy yeah
and yeah we might expect that even for
larger class of circuits that it's hard
in the worst case but so it also falls
on track to the approximation had one
but it the the easiness is also true
face is zero for example yeah mcsp s is
0 yeah but I'm going to get to this
later so I mean there's a key part of
what Russell Valentin ak Nina and Marco
did this come connection to learning so
hopefully it'll be a little bit of time
to go discuss that as well ok so I guess
it's all sorted I mean you could also
apply these observations to classes in
which you believe the one wave function
so it means that we expect TC 0 LC space
document right exactly even on average
right so somehow what these results tell
you is that and mcsp the sort of problem
where if you prove like a result in the
average case I mean 4c that's big enough
I mean we don't really know how to
distinguish the average case in the
worst case for like polynomial size
circles so if you tend to prove negative
results it tends to go through in the
average case as well which is perhaps a
reason why we aren't able to prove
stronger results because maybe yeah it's
a harder problem yeah
so ok so so there's this result the
Rudess result and this what it says what
I'm CSP in terms of class of boolean
functions so this is a respect to one
wave function assumption so Eric and
Beatrice had a result about szk so
SDK is just statistical zero knowledge
it's a class of functions that have zero
knowledge protocols that can't be
distinguished in statistically from
uniform and that's in VPP to the MCS be
so there's problem stick reductions to
mcsp and we believe there are problems
in SDK that are not in polynomial time
so this gives evidence just from boolean
complexity point of view that that mcsp
is hard and notice that we are using
cross stick reductions here so project
reductions are useful in this context at
least okay so so this is kind of like I
mean so the proof or the my proof
sketches is like really simple but I
think it has so this general framework
has quite deep implications and it kind
of indicates like connections between
soo randomness and the complexity of
mcsp because essentially they're saying
of cryptographic serum generators exist
then mcsp is hard on average right so
that these two regimes of C random
generators so there's a complexity
theoretic ones where your generators
allowed to use more resources than that
were sorry and the cryptographic one
where the adversary can run in time
polynomial and the size of the timing of
the generator right and these are
fundamentally different so so obviouly
saw and had construction the complexity
attic generators based on heart
functions in exponential time for
cryptographic generators we know them
based on one wave functions and I mean
for example if n P equals P you can
break any cryptographic generator but
that actually implies the complexity of
generators exist so there's like a
significant gap between these two
notions so hardness and exponential time
is closely connected is almost
equivalent to these complexity theoretic
generators existing and here we see that
if cryptographic generators exist mcsp
is hard so I think an actual conjecture
to make as it doesn't equivalence so we
can ask is this actually an equivalence
is there an equivalence between the
existence of one wave functions and mcsp
being hard on average for zero at our
algorithms and if this were the case
would be very interesting because it
would give a natural problem CSP for
which hardness on average in national
sense is equal to one wave functions so
let me just post that other question so
can we reverse the direction of Roswell
brood which can be sure
so no rules show that if one-way
functions exist then natural proofs
don't exist but they can we also show
that if natural pools don't exist then
one-way functions exist the existence of
one wave functions equivalent to mcsp
and have some recent results in this
direction but they don't have proof
positive answer to the question as yet
but but I think it's quite interesting
that looking at the right kind of like
this is a very natural distribution for
mcsp and the average case complexity
seems closely tied to or to see
randomness okay so in the show yeah
should be easy this of mcsp should be
equivalent to the non-existence of
non-uniform families of one wave
function versus uniform adversaries
right you believe that that's a stronger
statement
you mean the Russell rule does not also
establishes that and so you can
necessary yeah but it could be that
these two are equivalent to I mean so
that's I don't know of any kind of
evidence against that maybe we should
talk about it but yeah okay so now let
me say a little bit about the
connections with with learning
so I've mentioned like two important
papers in this area and in several
others but the cabinet side paper and
the rostral Routledge paper and I want
to talk about this a little bit about
this recent work of Valentin Russel
apnea and Marco
so let's first see what what does
learning have to do with mcsp right so
yeah let's go back to the comparison
with side right so yeah she's just
mentioned in passing that this whole
kind of like consideration of the
average case complexity of mcsp natural
proofs non-citizen natural proofs is
some other analog for mcsp of fiber
supports this facade and we've seen that
fibers hypothesis facade has lots of
implications and hardness of
approximation and so on so I think one
can expect that similarly looking at
natural proofs and the heart is mcsp one
might get similar implications that's
just in terms of extending this
comparison that's sad but for learning
so what is learning essentially so the
question so I've given Oracle access to
a function so that's just of course one
setting in which we do learning but it's
a setting that the most relevant to us
find my small hypothesis for explain so
yeah you've given Oracle access to a
function and you want to kind of quickly
find a small hypothesis it's consistent
with F on most inputs so that's one
natural setting which we do learning and
if you look at mcsp or the search
version of mcsp it's sort of clear that
there's a close relationship here right
so you give the truth table the boolean
function and you can use that to
simulate any sort of black box access
you want you have to a function and
given that you want to produce the
hypothesis namely you want to solve the
search problem you were to find a small
C circuit that's consistent with the
function for learning often the
requirements and complexity at terms are
quite strong you want to do it very
efficiently here we have time that's a
that's a polynomial size the truth table
so you have much more time but this kind
of relaxed version we're trying to find
small circuit and time followin size the
truth table is essentially search
version 11
be so search virtual MCS pain release to
run certainly learning algorithms are
likely to give us information about it
but there's connections are the other
ration and the sort of like a really
cool recent result of crkk so what they
show is that natural proofs or in other
words the easiness on average of mcsp
implies learnability right so
so what do I mean here so um so you NCS
be easy not easy on average we already
define what that means what do I mean by
a search version can be sort
approximately I just mean that well here
to solve the search question precisely
we want to get a circular size as it
represents the function exactly here we
are happy with having a circuit that is
correct on most inputs right so it's a
it's kind of good approximation to the
function and kind of Hamming distance
the small Hamming distance between the
truth table corresponding to the object
you output here and the function f and
that's the setting that you often have
in learning right so I mean it was open
until this paper how to get kind of
search to a decision reduction even for
mcsp right it's easy for sad if you know
how to solve sad in polynomial time you
can find a satisfying assignment just by
setting bets kind of incrementally and
checking satisfiability so it's an easy
search to decision reduction facade and
this is completely open for mcsp is
something we didn't know at all for mcsp
and now we have kind of a version of it
which is sort of interesting because we
are not have been using that mcsp is
easy generally only that is easy on
average and we're solving kind of the
search version approximately from it but
it's it's very interesting because
they're kind of versions of this result
so it's sort of implicit in this in this
paper but they've been kind of extension
so Shuichi has you know a recent paper
on it and there's some observations are
all people have made that this actually
gives kind of like an average cased
approximation connection right so when
CSP is easier than average you can
actually approximate the circuit size a
boolean function within some factor as
of now this connection only works for
approximation factor that's capitalized
the 1 minus epsilon or something like
that so that's quite large as the
function of the truth table slice but I
think a very interesting question is how
close can this connection be made so in
general find pick appeal problems we
don't
connections between average-case
easiness and kind of position or even
approximability so this is a big
question in complexity theory but mcsp
being kind of a mutual problem it is has
this this feature and I think it's
something that needs to be studied more
closely so what is the best
approximation factor that we can get for
for solving mcsp given that mcsp is easy
on average so that's that sound the
question that I did I have okay so I
don't have much time to say something on
the proof of this which is also very
interesting and again goes through
randomness but let me just mention in
the last couple of minutes or so a few
things about questions about lower
bounds
so question here is what unconditional
oh bonds can be show friends mcsp so for
sack if you have a low bar for an
explicit boolean function we can quite
often use efficient reductions to start
to get a similar lower bound for sat and
similarly for other np-complete problems
but for mcsp it seems to be like not as
straightforward to show lower bounds so
there's kind of a result of Erichs from
a while ago which shows that mcsp is not
an AC 0 and even that relies on
omniscience you're on generator so it
kind of follows by looking in Eastern
Soudan generator against AC 0 and and
analyzing that but it's still open
even if mcsp is an AC 0 of the parity so
there is something that that Eric
mentioned but I thought it realized it
because I think it's something that we
should be able to to solve and we don't
know how to
so mcsp it seems like a very hard
problem a zero parity is a class that we
seem to understand fairly well but you
know tables separate mcsp from AC no
parity what we are able to do so in
joint work with Shuichi is get some
formula lower bounds so mcsp of n2
little o1 is not an formulas
of sub-quadratic so um mcsp with kind of
like the parametrized version where it's
kind of sub polynomial doesn't a small
formula so it requires quadratic size
formulas so we can't say something about
formulas we don't get the best formula
lube bonds which are nearly cubic but we
have closed quadratic low bounds for
instead of parity we can't say anything
at all and just a sort of like a lead-in
to go stocks is next let me just mention
a recent result with him and yarn P yeah
if you don't know how to do it all the
four basis super linear lower bounds are
open so if they could do this so if you
could get um kind of super linear low
bounce against circuits n to the 1 plus
epsilon then this would imply that NP
not equal to P so so even super linear
circuit low bounce for this problem
would imply that NP naught equals P so I
mean of course if you could carry
through this connection for formulas
then we'll get NP naught and NC 1 but we
don't know how to Chi through the
connection for formulas performance we
can prove the lower bound for circuits
you know how to do the connection but of
course low bonds are out of reach so
it's kind of interesting perhaps
indicating kind of other barriers
towards proving low bounds and I think
that's that's something we thought about
more so yeah so I I guess talked about a
few connections with mcsp a and kind of
other areas and complexity theory
there's a lot that I wasn't able to talk
about so there's connections with proof
complexity with algebraic complexity the
common rock complexity as I mentioned
earlier and there's gonna be reading
group this this semester on mcsp will be
looking first of the cabinet's I paper
and crkk and maybe other papers so if
this in any of those interests you at
all and you're here for longer do come
along to that but that's all I have to
say for now
[Applause]
we're running a little into our break
time but let's go ahead and ask
questions
I think the CI KK result has some
bearing on your your question about
equivalence to one-way functions because
the best we know how to do as far as I
know assuming the non-existence of
one-way function is a very average case
notion of learning whereas this is the
worst is yeah so the paper we have
layered 11 on that this case yeah yeah
yeah right but as far as I can see I
mean this question is perfectly
plausible perhaps this I mean you think
he modern more perhaps it might not be
but if it's true I think it'll be very
interesting because it would connect
average-case complexity to cryptography
or in a very interesting way but yeah I
agree that is not it's not completely
clear if it's true or not I mean I have
some partial results and yeah but
let might have to do with the hardness
of learning hypothesis right I mean
those like and they are the questions if
I have tasty learnt you help to settle
itself the major questions in complexity
theory or is it just a problem your
incident think so no I and I think both
I mean it certainly it's kind of lagging
behind in terms of like there's some low
bounce we know how to use to show things
what mcsp but I think the connections
will see you randomness etcetera or
likely to be useful and kind of low
bounce approaches so yeah there is kind
of a connection both to thank you maybe
one can prove someone the bottom is it
for like simple circles it's hard
because you can sort of in writes it in
this way but for in for like expressing
circuits it's hard because of the one
thing yes so that's very interesting
question so there's a gap right so for
DNF mcsp or [ __ ] slightly more than that
we have evidence of harness from
np-hardness
for like TC zero depth for and higher we
have evidence cryptographic hardness put
water in between we don't have any
evidence of hardness at all so far so at
least that we should be able to bridge
in some way hopefully I mean so that's I
think that that's an interesting
question
but yeah it's for very simple complexity
measures like dilution trees and it's
it's easily doable I'm CSP is it's kind
of in polynomial time across a
polynomial time so at a certain point
with DNS it becomes np-hard I mean my
own belief will be that stays np-hard
for circuits but it's going to be not so
easy to show
last call for questions thank you
[Applause]